[Music]
so
[Music]
this is sky news live from the city with
a special programme on the war in
ukraine and what it means for the global
economy coming up this hour under attack
the financial as well as humanitarian
damage in ukraine we'll hear from
business leaders there about the
economic disaster and what will be
needed to help the country rebuild
volatility on the markets continues amid
the uncertainty with the price of oil
falling below 100 a barrel for the first
time in a fortnight
russia hit with more sanctions including
extra tariffs on vodka in the latest
push to help isolate the country
plus rebuilding ukraine we'll hear from
the uk-based entrepreneurs trying to
help their home country
[Music]
good evening what has happened during
the last 20 days in ukraine has shocked
the world vladimir putin's war has seen
cities bombarded hundreds of civilians
killed and three million people flee the
country as well as the humanitarian cost
there is of course a huge economic cost
to ukraine impossible to estimate at the
moment but the scale of the war means
the effects are also being felt right
across the globe
over the next hour i'll be speaking to
analysts economists and business people
to find out what the war in ukraine
means for the global economy and whether
it could snuff out the post-pandemic
recovery but first to ukraine itself a
little earlier i spoke to sergey sivkach
he's the executive director of ukraine
invest he spoke to me from the capital
kiev about the damage being done by the
russians in ukraine
they did
great damage to ukrainian economy
and they did great damage also to
regional and to global economy i will
tell you
one example
ukraine is a big agricultural country
we are 42 million people in the center
of europe
but we feed more than 150 million people
worldwide
last year we managed to harvest
more than 85 million
tons of grain crops
this year if we will not manage to do
sowing works and they have to start now
you can imagine what's going to happen
and about half of our harvest was
exported to all countries throughout the
world so this could be a humanitarian
crisis that will affect not only ukraine
but the whole world it is very important
now
to stop this war you know our president
our politicians our people they scream
out loud
saying
asking for a no-fly zone and this is
still not happening
so
this will have a very serious effect on
ukraine region and the whole globe
apart from the issue over the no-fly
zone are there any other sanctions that
the west could be applying to russia
well we have seen sanctions we have seen
many sanctions but some of them like
swift disconnection for example it's not
a full disconnection so some banks some
you know intermediaries they still use
swift so ukraine definitely wants to see
proper sanctions solid sanctions that
will have immediate effect in russia
there is no room for half measures at
the moment
obviously in your role at ukraine invest
you speak to partners from all over the
world what have you heard from
investors like the chinese who are
obviously being quite ambivalent in
terms of how they're playing this
well we didn't see many chinese uh
investments in ukraine we have been
approached by chinese investors many
times but
we didn't see
real investments in ukrainian economic
economy so far
at the moment we can
only
say that
they probably still interested but
obviously we do not talk to investors
right now about investments we talked to
investors about the ways we can support
them one of the key issues right now is
support in terms of relocation from
affected regions to western ukraine we
are 24 7 in touch with investors
ukrainian and foreign investors when we
are helping them to do so
and
we will need
to have some solid
analog of marshall plan in ukraine the
plan that was created by united states
for european countries after the second
world war
and this will have to be a very solid
pragmatic and a very well planned
you know way to recover ukrainian
economy
it will also require a vast amount of
money is it possible do you think to put
a figure on the kind of
money that might be needed in in
reconstruction
well at the moment our officials talk
about negative effects at level of about
120 billion u.s dollars
but these are
very you know preliminary assessments
and i'm sure that the figure will be
much higher
and in terms of the kind of things that
would be needed
presumably restoring damaged
infrastructure will be will be the
priority
damaged infrastructure bridges airports
because airports where targets number
one for uh russians
also
residential houses
only in harkev city the city that is
near the russian border
already
more than 600
residential buildings destroyed 600 and
i'm talking about
nine story 12 story uh buildings you
know so this is it's
we cannot even calculate
appropriately now how much money we will
need in kiev
we do not need alarm anymore
unfortunately because every morning 5
a.m sharp
they send missiles and missiles are sent
to hit residential houses
not military targets
just next to me 700 meters away
the
residential house was hit yesterday at 5
00
pm
today same story in kiev at least five
civilians were dead at 5 00 am today so
it's a very important topic you know to
discuss enough no no-fly zone our
president
also said if there is no possibility
to introduce a full-scale no-fly zone
then ukraine needs to receive
anti-missile systems
[Music]
well let's have a look at how the global
markets have fared today and it's fair
to say that equity markets in the
asia-pacific region had a pretty torrid
session following a surge of covert
cases in china and hong kong concerns
over whether the war in ukraine could
spark fresh trade tensions between the
u.s and china the nikkei in tokyo
managed to eke out a modest gain sydney
was more or less unchanged but in
shanghai and mumbai there were big falls
in shanghai the shanghai composite
actually fell by nearly five percent as
you can see there meanwhile the hang
seng in hong kong well that is in bear
market territory haven't fallen by 26
from its most recent peak and by 10.4
so far this week well in europe stocks
have traded largely to the downside
today here's how they finished you can
see uh the uh cacarant in france was the
biggest single faller there off by just
under a quarter of one percent here in
london the ftse 100 suffered its reverse
first reverse in three sessions it
finished down by a quarter of one
percent the mining heavyweights glencore
rio tinto an anglo-american were among
the main drags on the index the
educational publisher pearson was the
leading gainer that rose by 8
as the market awaits takeover
developments on wall street meanwhile
well the three main us stock indices the
s p 500 the dow jones industrial average
and the nasdaq composite all enjoyed
their first gains in three sessions
airline stocks are among the leading
gainers after executives of several
carriers told an investor conference
that they were expecting to see a faster
expected recovery in demand well joining
me now from new york is mickey levy he's
chief economist for the americas and
asia at berenbach capitol markets mickey
welcome to you i'm looking at the s p
and the nasdaq i mean they're very
little changed since putin launched his
invasion what does that tell us about
how u.s equity investors view the war
well
uncertainty is just the only word that
comes up and just just the you know the
heartbreaking uh
the uh the devastation to ukraine is
just that's just dominating everybody
and but it's uncertainty and so today
you know oil prices were down uh big
and the markets went up but who knows
about tomorrow everything is dominated
by
you know the uncertainty what we don't
know here is
we we know that this is going to add to
inflation which
is going to have a big negative effect
what we don't know is the extent to
which this is going to further
aggravate global supply chains uh
disruptions to production and
distribution
and and while one can expect that the
uncertainty is going to have
you know probably a bigger impact or
more pronounced impact on on
europe it's going to be felt in the u.s
there's no question
well of course all eyes are on the
federal reserve the feds meeting
tomorrow we're expecting the first
interest rate hike since december 2018.
you've actually written in the wall
street journal today that they should
press ahead
well well that's right and and so the
reason is i mean the backdrop is
inflation's already risen way above
where the fed had had been predicting
it's way above where
it's comfortable um labor markets are
very tight and and
when we think in economic terms the
russian invasion of ukraine
operates like a negative supply shock
the fed cannot do anything about it
but it does have to deal with the
underlying very high inflation and very
tight labor markets and when we think
about it the federal funds futures has
already
built in expectations of
about over six
25 basis point increases in the federal
funds rate this year
and this is already reflected in in say
one and two year treasury note yields so
when the fed actually starts hiking
rates to
to reign in
the underlying rate of inflation um it
shouldn't have any impact on markets
because it's already built in always
already built into expectations and it
really shouldn't have any impact on the
economy and here i would note
when we look at the federal funds rate
that's anchored to zero
at the same time inflation has zoomed
the u.s has never faced such a large
negative gap between the funds rate and
inflation in its history and at the same
time the fed's balance sheet is is is
nine trillion dollars
the financial markets are awash with
liquidity so it's wise for the fed to uh
start to proceed to move toward a more
neutral monetary policy um while keeping
an eye on how
global events uh you know
affect um affect economic behavior i
mean mickey we learned today that
u.s producer price inflation is was
above 10 last month for the second month
running i mean it feels as so inflation
the gd may already be out of the bottle
well
you're i mean you're bringing out a
great point there
to me at least and many others there's
no question but that the fed
really uh
read all of the inflation and monetary
and fiscal policy signals wrong last
year and it should have started moving
toward normalizing policies mid last
year
and now it's really behind
and you're exactly right when we look at
agricultural commodity prices which have
been clearly aggravated by by
russia's invasion of ukraine when we
look at
industrial metals prices
and energy prices there's no question
but the the producer costs are
accelerating
and with the strong demand at least in
the u.s businesses have that flexibility
to raise prices so so once again the fed
should be
focusing on
the um the underlying rate of inflation
and inflation is going to rise here
further in the near term and
it's when we if you were to just look at
the evening news in
in the united states or any local news
there are only two topics that
absolutely dominate it one is is
ukraine and the other is how in high
inflation is is pinching on people's
pocketbooks that's that's the news and
the fed has to begin addressing it
uh briefly if you would please mickey
how much concern are you picking up
about anxieties over a trade war with
china being reignited by what's going on
in ukraine
it's definitely in in the discussion and
so so there there are so many
um uncertainties and and and
i would note that you know once again
um
while the us does not have
significant exports to china it relies
very heavily on imports from china
and
you know everybody can read the tea
leaves and and clearly you know china is
um
you know going to be supporting russia
and its initiatives in various ways and
china relies very heavily on russia for
natural gas and
and um there is this concern that
um
the russia's invasion of
of ukraine
escalates from here and that's certainly
a risk and and this is being
this has been it should be reflected in
in global portfolio managers thinking
about what might happen to asset prices
what might happen to to the economies
and i think it's almost in the cards
that
global trade
relative to global output is going to
diminish some and and i would expect
this is a
important wake-up call and you're going
to see companies starting to reassess
their supply chains as as they should
all right mickey we've got to leave it
there always good to talk to you thanks
very much indeed for joining me tonight
well one of the most far-reaching
consequences of the war has been a big
increase in the price of many
commodities and in particular those
produced by russia and ukraine coffin
aluminium two very important industrial
metals have traded at record prices
since the invasion while trading in
nickel a key component in electric
vehicle batteries was suspended on
tuesday last week by the london metal
exchange after the price quadrupled in
just two days well the price of wheat 30
of which globally came from russia and
ukraine before the war rose by 55
in the days after the invasion the most
dramatic impact though as far as
consumers will be concerned are in oil
and gas prices well brent crude right
now is currently trading at 98.49
about that's down by just under 8
on the day but let me show you what's
been going on with the price of brent
crude over the last month as you can see
it peaked on monday last week at nearly
140 dollars a barrel has come rattling
back since then but there's a good deal
of volatility in the market right now
well here you can see what's happened to
the price of copper over the last month
as well a similar picture there copper
at one point uh coming uh to hitting a
new all-time high as well again a very
very important metal in terms of what it
means for the global economy
well earlier i spoke to amrita sen she's
chief oil analyst at the research
consultancy energy aspects she told me a
big factor behind the recent volatility
is a lack of liquidity in energy markets
banks are being very very cautious in
lending uh to
to any participant that trades in
russian commodities which by the way is
enormous in terms of not just the volume
russia produces but the intermediaries
uh the trading houses oil majors mean
this is an enormous uh business when it
comes to not again not just oil and gas
but across the commodity business so
there is genuinely a lack of liquidity
in the market right now if you look at
margins uh so all the exchanges
intercontinental exchange for instance
has been raising margins for crude by 32
overnight uh last week the same they've
done for diesel as well so people are
having to put up more capital just to be
able to maintain their positions but
also sometimes being forced to liquidate
and this is really the biggest paralysis
i've seen since 2008 in the market i
mean on that basis i mean brent crude is
off some 30 from the peak that it hit
just eight days ago would you expect
that volatility to continue
volatility absolutely yes do i think the
correction is justified by fundamentals
no
obviously the price move higher was
equally driven by the geopolitical risks
around russia the reality is that we
were expecting prices to go above 100
before the russian crisis we were
expecting that to happen late this year
into next year um we have been talking
about genuinely running out of crude
stocks in the summer because of what has
been going on uh in term just the sheer
tightness in the market with the lack of
supply and demand picking up so nothing
has changed if anything we are starting
to lose russian barrels so the market is
going to be tighter but it's not going
to be a straight line higher for prices
it's going to be immensely volatile i
mean on that basis i mean it's the
received wisdom is that the uae and
saudi arabia are not going to be enough
to compensate for lost russian
production is that actually your
understanding of the situation
absolutely you know we've been talking
about the lack of spare capacity for
almost a year and a half now and a lot
of people were asking us questions that
are you guys sure i think the market has
come around to our view yes saudi arabia
and uae have spare capacity over and
above the current opec deal they could
increase production
but again even if they brought
everything forward it's not going to be
enough to compensate for say let's say
three million barrels per russian
production that could be at risk in
april but also i think saudi arabia
knows very well that should it bring all
the production capacity it has up front
what happens is summer when seasonally
demand picks up so this is what they're
trying to juggle right now and really
keep the market as stable as possible do
you have any optimism that iranian crude
is going to return to the market anytime
soon
it's complicated now uh with russia's
involvement there's been some movement
today uh with russia saying that you
know yes it's received some u.s
guarantees that it can continue to trade
with iran after the deal but no by no
means is it a done deal we've had
obstacles before but of course russia uh
getting itself involved with vis-a-vis
what's going on in ukraine does
definitely throw a spanner in the works
we are still expecting a deal to be done
uh over the second uh quarter of this
year with barrels starting to hit the
market in the third quarter but right
now that's definitely uh not as certain
as it was even let's say uh 10 days ago
now the market does appear to have been
self sanctioning or russian ga oil and
gas but that crude is still finding its
way to asia isn't it
not as much as one would expect yes
india bought a few cargos uh the espo
pipeline that goes to china and the s4
barrels cargos that go to japan and
korea that is flowing that's another
great not euros that's going to asia
china still buying it but when it comes
to euros that is not going in the same
volume to asia as many people had
expected it's not that china and india
don't want to take it they are just
trying to sort out payment issues
because the banking sanctions and the
swift sanctions have made it very
difficult for payment and i think that's
what the main issue is right now
and yes remember right now a lot of the
cargos that are loading are cargos that
had been booked pre-sanctioned so they
will still flow even to europe this
month the real hit to loadings will only
come from april so i think there's a
little bit of a misconception around
this is just that
the asian barrels that you're seeing
being loaded today they were bought
pre-war
it's the new barrels that need to be
loaded from april that that's where
you're going to see the real issues and
which will force russia to shut in some
production
now the world bank has announced an
extra 200 million dollars of funding for
ukraine on top of the 723 million
dollars it had already promised well the
initial loans are designed to support
critical services in ukraine including
wages for hospital workers pensions for
the elderly and social programmes for
the vulnerable but what will be needed
in the longer term in the country well
joining me now from vienna is axel von
trotzenberg the world bank's managing
director of operations uh very good
evening to you sir uh i mean this 200
million is part of a 3 billion overall
package that the world bank has
announced when do you expect all of that
to be dispersed
well we have been dispersing very
quickly we had last week a discussion at
our board that was approved and a 500
million dollars have been disbursed so
we are moving very fast we have
announced that up to three billion
dollars of support uh can be expected
from the world bank so we have now again
190 million dollars and we are preparing
two operations of 500 million each
now we heard earlier in the program
calls for a martial plan to help
reconstruct ukraine after the war
whenever that may be
is that something that the world bank
could do on its own or is that going to
require a much bigger multi-national
effort
well you're right this will need to uh
require a worldwide effort to support
ukrainian its reconstruction but as you
know the world bank was created after
the second world war we have in our
original name they are the
reconstruction international bank for
reconstruction and development
reconstruction will be very very
important the world bank is ready we
have a huge experience in this and we
stand ready to support ukraine in all
its efforts in their reconstruction at
this stage of course we will need to
continue to support them to get through
this crisis and hopefully that piece
will come soon
is there any
kind of number that you could possibly
come up with to say how much post-war
reconstruction of ukraine might cost
i think it is very difficult because as
you see the longer the work uh lasts the
more the damages and the more financial
needs will be required so i think it is
premature to to speculate what is very
clear is that ukraine will require an
enormous amount of support and that is
for the reconstruction we will also not
need to forget that the fallout of this
uh of this war is also felt in many
developing countries you were just
talking about the impacts of of energy
prices as well as on
agriculture prices and this hits
particularly poor countries so we will
see a much much bigger global effect
particularly on the developing world
which will also require billions of
dollars of financial support
now obviously the international
sanctions are also hurting russia a
great deal if vladimir putin was to turn
around tomorrow and sue for peace and
give back the land that he's taken how
would the world bank look upon an appeal
for him from him for help
well uh this is governed by by our abort
i think our first focus and certainly
our board is focused single-mindedly on
ukraine to support it against this
invasion and this is the main focus so i
don't think that the board or anybody
else has been focusing on a speculative
idea of supporting russia right now i
think we will need to focus first to
help ukraine it's its re reconstruction
efforts and then see how the
international community will react to
russia's actions
i mean russia faces two
interest payments tomorrow on the dollar
denominated bonds that has gone an issue
do you fear the consequences if russia
defaults on those payments
i think this was anticipated with the
sanctions i think what is very much more
important is that there is international
solidarity with ukraine and and
therefore you see that uh
uh many countries have taken uh very
serious uh sanctions vis-a-vis uh russia
and i think that is anticipated that
there will be defaults but the most
important thing is let's keep in mind
that ukraine is under attack
and just to go back to something that we
discussed at the very beginning the the
amount of money that you've given and
are giving to ukraine are those grants
or just loans
these are these are loans and we have
received uh some uh support from about
five uh from about six countries for
about 140
million dollars including a generous
grant by the uk government of about 100
million pounds
all right axel von trotzenberg good to
talk to you this morning uh this evening
thank you
thank you very much
is a mother of today's developments now
and the uk and the eu today impose bans
on the export of luxury goods and
vehicles art jewelry and high-end
fashion to russia in the latest push to
isolate the country the uk is also
slapping 35 tariffs on a range of
russian products sold in this country
including russian vodka metals
fertilizers and other commodities
meanwhile the eu has introduced an
import ban on russian steel and steel
products that are estimated to cover
some 3.3 billion euros worth of products
separately the uk today announced that
it was freezing the assets of 300 more
russians including 50 oligarchs and
members of their families those covered
by the new restrictions include mikhail
friedman and peter aven whose letter one
investment company owns the health food
retailer holland and barrett meanwhile
the eu has added new names to its list
of russians who've been made subject to
an asset freeze and travel ban they
include roman abramovich the owner of
chelsea football club who was first
sanctioned by the uk on thursday last
week
and russia claimed tonight it had
received guarantees from the united
states that sanctions imposed on moscow
will not be allowed to affect his trade
with iran well the guarantee if true
would remove a stumbling block to iran
reviving a 2015 deal with the west under
which the islamic republic would reign
back its nuclear programme in return for
an easing of western sanctions will that
in turn could see more iranian crude oil
being released onto global markets
signatures to the original 2015 deal
apart from the united states included
germany france the uk russia and china
now forecasting global growth is not
easy at the moment with the war in
ukraine being so unpredictable
well joining me now is aaron captain
he's chief economist at ubs aaron very
good to see you today you've published a
range of scenarios the most uh downbeat
one of which is a recession in europe
how do we get to that state of affairs
to get to recession you would need um
physical disruption to energy supplies
so so it's not enough to just have a
price shock
you would need to see some disruption so
what we assumed in our in our scenarios
is a 50 cut in um
oil and gas supply from russia to europe
that equates to about eight percent of
all european energy consumption and then
you'd have a bunch of offsets where um
europe would be able to substitute some
of that energy supply but you still end
up with um about a 400 basis point
decline in in growth in europe relative
to the pre-invasion baseline
but on your base case uh you've just cut
your global growth forecast from 4.6 to
3.6 percent that might not strike two
people as being too
apocalyptic
yeah so all that's in there at this
stage is just the the move in commodity
prices since the invasion and so rough
rule of thumb is every you know ten
dollars in oil takes about a tenth off
of um off of growth as you've showed on
your chart you know we've had oil moving
and i mean intraday it actually reached
about 140 so it's been sort of in a you
know that that range alone is worth
about 50 basis points of of global
growth effectively and so what we've
done is is two things so one is um you
know we've taken on board the inflation
hits to
global consumers so there's an erosion
of real disposable income
but then the other thing you need to
take on board is that there's going to
be some supply chain disruption we you
know we're tracking satellite data of
the number of ships going to russia that
is
completely collapsed so that's down by
50
in just the last couple of weeks so
there's going to be some trade
disruption and then we're already
getting reports from um you know auto
producers for instance of supply
shortages of particular parts that are
being manufactured in ukraine so for
instance wire harnesses
um is is a part for cars that are that
are already being disrupted and so
taking it all together you know about 60
of that um downward revision was sort of
the rest of the world but the other bits
russia
right so russia i mean
you were showing i think a number from
the imf for ukraine on the screen all
these things are guesses right now but
russia we think is going to contract in
the baseline already by about 10
uh this year and so that is 40 of the
downward revision in global growth
now one of the key weapons that the west
has utilized against russia is
restricting its ability to trade in u.s
dollars
does that potentially force russia to
use other currencies and which ones does
it go for presumably it's the renminbi
well so so far it's quite partial so
they um you know the swift exclusions do
not apply to the entire banking system
so at this stage it is still possible to
transact with russian bank they've
actually some of the the banks through
which normally the west conducts their
energy business with russia are still
not on that swift list so um so at this
stage
that may still happen it may be that
um that that the west is effectively
sort of giving their own banks some more
time to lay the groundwork for a more
broad-based exclusion from from swift
which would then really make it
difficult um but yeah they don't have a
lot of options so um uh because the you
know all aside from china so all the
other currencies in the g7 the usable
currencies are all going to be subject
to those constraints
and so the question is indeed you know
can can they can they use renminbi and
are other countries willing to
transact in that and i think that
remains to be seen i mean dow jones has
reported this evening that saudi arabia
may price some of its oil sales to china
in renminbi does that in any way chip
away at the dollar's supremacy globally
so
look so ultimately i think the um
the sanctions that have been imposed
including the freeze of the central
bank's uh reserves
um all those are are things that are
going to uh undermine a little bit the
confidence in
um i mean not just the dollar but that's
sort of the safety of
um of effectively you know g7 uh
currencies in terms of having your money
invested in them and and to go through
their financial system so i mean for for
some regimes you know there will be some
diversification i think on the back of
this where um they i mean this is pretty
unprecedented the the restrictions that
have been imposed and so there's going
to be a global rethink i think on the
part of some governments as to
um you know how dependent they want to
be on um on the dollar
financial banking system
all right aaron captain good to talk to
you this evening thanks very much indeed
well still to come here only in king
life the british base company concerned
for its workers in the city of dunepro
as ukraine's manufacturing facilities
come under attack don't go away
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back now many companies with
facilities in ukraine are worried about
what will happen to their workers there
well today the british rocket company
skyroa announced a new engine testing
facility in scotland ukraine has a
strong history in this base sector and
skyroa was founded by ukrainian and has
a research and development team in
dunepro well joining me now is sky roar
as chief executive vladimir leverkin
vladimir very good evening to you first
of all how are you all people in disney
pro
uh so far
reasonably all right
so the nipples so far
just experienced a few missile strike in
comparison with mario but it's nothing
basically
so and our people are safe at the moment
thank you are you trying are you trying
to get any of them and their families
out of the country
uh
yes some of them whenever it is possible
please mind that the male cannot leave
the country unless there are let's say
either very young or very old or they
have a three kids so basically remove
the people who has
more than three kids
uh and we also have some people who
basically start
just be at the beginning of the war they
appear to be here in the uk in the
business trip
so our primary goal was basically to
care about their families and assist as
much as we can and support them as much
as we can from here
now you're aiming to be the first
british company to launch a an orbital
launch from uk soil has the war put any
of that in jeopardy has it pushed your
plans off course
yeah no even though that's our main
everything facility manufacturing
facility engine test that you mentioned
here in edinburgh and glasgow area
however
of course the war in europe will have an
impact on everyone including us of
course and we're now trying to assess
what the impact would be and how to
regroup and how to optimize the process
and to minimize the impact on our
operations
now ukraine has a very very proud and
strong tradition in in space in the
space sector how did that come about
what were the origins
so the nebra basically the city which we
are based on in in ukraine
it's used to be this the space hub of
the soviet union right more than ten
thousand rockets uh missiles icbms been
built there right including the the
latest human zenith rocket which elon
musk's
once named as the second best rocket in
the world right now
so uh which is which is right um place
to be in for us right
and it seems to be that is one of the
assets which is russia desired to
capture
and obviously the deeper is protected
well and i believe that will never
happen and we will win and of course the
world's biggest uh aircraft the antonov
was designed and built uh by ukrainians
yeah exactly uh yeah
in kiev and antonov and as you know it's
been unfortunately destroyed during the
first date which is absolutely
uh let's say
disaster
uh
as any other disasters which russia
caused in ukraine but that one
particular will have an impact on
aerospace industry because that was
widely used to transport large
satellites across the globe and whenever
it it was such a unique uh plane is
needed it was always in duty but it's
gone now and it's gone forever
that is heartbreaking
what do you think
putin is up to in terms of the space
industry specifically do you think he is
trying to get his hands on some of the
technology that uh exists in ukraine
oh
okay so i i'm
i think nobody is capable to comment
what what this
mr putin does right
um
i think that the techniques which they
use right now which is basically uh
flattering the sieges will destroy all
kinds of ips and and assets which they
just did with antonov right
so i think that his desire is completely
different he's not rational
and he's not thinking about how to get
technology from ukraine he's thinking
about how to
destroy ukraine as a country and as a
nation my personal opinion
this must be a very very difficult time
for you personally
uh
i mean the number of millions of people
who has a way worse situation than
myself personally because i'm based here
in edinburgh and
you know what you need to care about
it's basically not my personal life and
my personal family
but people in our company which i try to
do all my best to take care of them but
believe me there are millions of people
who really really
in in in
terrible terrible conditions
right now in ukraine
well vladimir we wish you all the very
best thank you very much indeed for
joining me this evening thank you thank
you very much thank you
well before the war there were some 32
000 people born in the ukraine living in
the uk many of them working in the tech
sector well one of them is ira ali alaki
who joined us earlier in the year to
talk about her company zamner whose
technology helps airlines and travel
authorities securely share and verify
passenger identities but she stepped
back from that to set up sunflower an
organization trying to get aid into
ukraine where era joins me now era very
good to see you this evening first of
all you i know you have family in
ukraine are they all safe
as safe as they can be given that now
nowhere in ukraine is safe from sunday
western ukraine has seen shelling in
bombing and actually overnight i started
helping to evacuate part of my family
which is just not straightforward given
the situation
so tell me about sunflower what are you
specifically looking to achieve
so sunflower relief is connecting
immediate needs on the ground in ukraine
to age that is looking for a way in fast
as you mentioned i was born in the
ukraine ian and i left when i was nine
but sunflower relief is unique because
even though we're in the uk
we myself and my team speak all three
languages that are local to the borders
polish russian and ukrainian and we're
fast creating this network and building
meaningful relationships to both source
and verify high integrity organizations
or individuals who are already serving
the local community on the ground
so what are the main challenges been in
in getting things across the border
i mean the logistical challenge of
sunflower is scaling people in process
which as a
founder and ceo of tech companies i'm
now i'm very used to doing
one of the biggest issues we have is
that we're seeing lots of brilliant aid
efforts happening
and there's such complexity that so many
organizations need to come together to
form links in that chain from eight
being donated to eight going on the
ground to the end receiver fast and
they're struggling to get it deep enough
into the country sometimes because
ukraine is largely rural and very
difficult to actually navigate so for
example we have a donor in the us right
now who is donated funds
through an ngo to buy some supplies for
a network of orphanages in ukraine that
we've established connections with and
they can't wait they need this aid fast
and that's what we're delivering today
and trying to overcome those challenges
with the one advantage that we do have
which is our linguistic barrier that we
can overcome and our deep and personal
connected network on the ground
and i gather the fact that you've worked
closely with the aviation industry with
zam now that has come that has been a
big help for you as well
it's been extraordinary the response
i've seen at very senior levels from
aviation executives willing to donate
cargo space uh cargo capacity going into
particular ports uh airline hangars to
store this aid even seats that you would
have seen many companies donate to get
people out of the difficult conflict
zone so i think the response has been
overwhelming and helping the people that
i know and want to help in the ukraine
has definitely been held by the fact
that i've built a strong network and
also friendships as ceo examiner working
with airlines
now obviously you've built your life in
this country you've built a business in
this country are you perhaps casting
your mind ahead a few years down the
line in terms of how you might help out
in a sort of reconstruction drive for
ukraine
absolutely and there are two very
distinct phases as my aid workers are
educating me about this
the initial immediate fast relief on the
ground is just phase one phase two very
much is developmental aid and this is
why building meaningful and deep
networks will help us make inroads and
create that infrastructure that until
two weeks ago we didn't really need to
build for aids to continuously come in
and help ukraine recover from this
there are a lot of people watching will
be wondering how they can help out what
uh should anyone do if they're
interested
i'll say three things the first one is
that if you're a business
looking to put together age packages we
can connect you to high integrity vested
and trusted connections on the ground
directly the second one is if you're an
institution and you're looking to donate
funds do consider us and help us scale
very fast and finally and most
importantly if you're a ukrainian
speaking individual who wants to
volunteer and support our efforts please
do get in touch with us
all right here well best of luck with
everything you're doing and uh also very
importantly best of luck to all of your
family i hope they stay safe thanks for
joining me thank you ian
well still to come here or in king life
what next to the global economy as the
war in ukraine threatens to stop the
pandemic recovery in its tracks don't go
away
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they have breached the road there is a
lot of gas being fired all around us
[Music]
it is an absolute carnival kind of
atmosphere out here for prime minister
modi's despite the victory
these
students find the prohibitory order and
now they're going to be arrested
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
the roads have been inundated the only
way out is to get people by boat
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today it's
absolutely deserted
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
[Music]
welcome back well over the last hour
we've been looking at the damage that's
been done to the global economy since
vladimir putin decided to invade ukraine
the big question now is what will happen
next and how might the balance of
economic power change in coming months
well joining me now is peter oppenheimer
he's chief global equity strategist at
goldman sachs peter welcome to you at
the beginning of the year it was all
about
inflation reflation now the the buzz is
all around stagflation are we heading in
that direction
uh hello ian uh i i think we are first
of all of course um my thoughts with all
the people affected by this awful
humanitarian disaster but as you say
there are economic effects as well
towards the end of last year
markets were very much focused on rising
inflation but strong economic growth
alongside that
and as a result of those things rising
interest rates particularly in the us
but now the effect of this war has been
to push up inflation expectations even
further because of surging commodity
prices
but that's also hitting growth
expectations and that combination
is often described as stagflationary
it's the worst of both worlds in a sense
because you have rising interest rates
and higher inflation but weaker growth
we don't think there'll be recessions
but across europe which is most affected
by the rising commodity prices
we will see likely a period of at least
stagnation and maybe a quarter or two of
negative
growth as well
peter we don't want to send people off
to bed with nightmares i mean when you
talk about stagflation we're not
necessarily talking about something akin
to the 70s oil shock
no i think that's right
a lot of the
energy price surges that we're seeing
will start to fade out over time
and it's important to understand that
we're starting from a point of
extraordinarily low inflation that we've
really enjoyed over the last decade or
more and of course very low rate
interest rates most countries have
interest rates close to zero so even as
we see
gradually rising interest rates uh to
offset the effects of these rising
prices we're still talking about very
low levels relative to history and at
the same time we're seeing much more
government support coming through in the
uk and across europe in terms of fiscal
policy
and private sector balance sheets are
quite strong so that at least is a
positive offset
um in the light of
this shock that we're seeing at the
moment
obviously there was a lot of hope at the
beginning of this year that uh 2022
would be a year in which business
investment took off that there'd be an
increase in capex around the world with
all this uncertainty that feels rather
unlikely
well of course when you get a shock of
this nature and it is really very
shocking it does dent optimism and
confidence at least in the short term
but i would say that at the same time
the moves towards decarbonization and
the urgency now that this is uh facing
given the requirements to become more
energy independent
particularly across europe is going to
result in a lot more spending i think a
lot more capex infrastructure spending
on alternative energy on renewables and
also on defense and this will over time
create more opportunities for growth and
i think we will see a big pick up in
investment spending relative to what
people were expecting perhaps a few
months ago and also we are still seeing
as you said that the beginnings of uh
the opening up of some of the service
parts of the economy uh as we hopefully
come out of the pandemic peter you
mentioned defense spending there in
particular i mean the important thing
about the defense sector is that there's
quite a big multiplier effect isn't
there a pound spent on defense goes a
lot further in terms of boosting growth
elsewhere in the economy
it does and also historically it's had
quite positive effects on other
technologies
and on creating jobs
we do have quite a strong job market
labor market is quite tight here in the
u.s and across europe
so the increase in spending on that area
and indeed on other infrastructure
related to energy development i think
will be a positive over the longer run
and of course we were already seeing
partly as a result of the pandemic
many companies bringing back operations
and production to more local sites
across europe the uk and elsewhere and
that will create more job opportunities
and growth opportunities okay as well
peter got to leave it there thanks for
joining me tonight
much appreciated up next the news at 10
don't go away
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
[Music]
you